so guys you are looking quite fantastic
I must say whom I got with me here today
storm Georgia and I'm Jamie the Riddler
and why did you try to come as storm
today well it's my birthday today and as
a birthday present my friends went out
and bought me the material and stuff but
to make it and I love storm I love x-men
so happy birthday as well and why the
Riddler oh well I'm a huge Batman fan
and it's got a wealth of villains and
winners my favorite says you're looking
forward to Dark Knight Rises so much so
much I cannot wait and storm as well I
mean a fantastic character what is it
you like about in particular I like the
fact that she's strong she does her own
things and it's not just the fact that
she's got powers she's also kick-ass
herself but I really like that she's
quite edgy a little bit like me I wish I
had the same fast you did you found it
the whole series it's about all the
other characters yeah I love it
I honestly do my dad's a huge sort of
Marvel fan and watch stuff like that
together so it's nice did your friends
brought you the stuff for it did you put
it together though as well with them and
help me with the cave and slip down the
trims and the boots and stuff it was
partly bought it was all quite
last-minute because we weren't really
expecting it but it's yeah
look incredible so if you done this kind
of cosplay stuff before no this is our
first time here so I absolutely love it
I didn't realize this will be so many
people and it's really nice thing
everyone putting in so much effort I
think it's fantastic do you like to do
it again and what would you come as next
time you think I'm not sure I've always
wanted to go as Chiana from Farscape
but I have to sort of get little makeup
tips or something from someone to get
the gray color you got eyes how do they
feel they're little itchy it's all right
every now and then I still go to the
toilet bit water on but the most part
they're fine yeah you're doing really
well and how about you if you first
cosplay if you didn't see fall we're
doing it for her birthday so it's a nice
little treat to the day I don't join you
so much so far do you like to do if you
do it again in future and who would you
like to come as you think oh I think
I'll probably try Rorschach from
Watchmen yeah I think that's always not
something happens very often so like
here we go like what did you have to do
to put this outfit together
okay well um I actually set my
housemates on a mad hunt to find these
leggings which are actually pretty
liberating and Georgia was clever enough
to draw me in some question marks yeah
it was a pretty easy
well guys enjoy the rest of show you
both look fantastic and have a good
weekend
you